تمرد بعد الصحف الاخوانيه في ايه في عهد
ثوره يوليو
تحديدا اا مجله الدعوه
لصدر السنه 51 استمرت ربما العام 57 ااا
واحد الاعداد احتفى بذكر حسن البنا لكن
يعني شعره ان ربما يعني السلطه تضيق بهذا
وتوقفت الامر الى ان صدرت مره اخرى في عهد
الرئيس السادات وهمم ضلت همم تصدر الى
يعني همم نهايه السبعينات اوائل
الثمانينات بل الى وفاه صاحب الامتياز همم
ايضا همم في في عهد ما ما بعد همم
الرئيس عبد الناصر ثم الرئيس السادات همم
بعد ان افرج عن الاخوان حين اصدرها
الاخوان مجله الدعوه برئاسه عمر الترم
الثاني حرص على يعني توزع اعداد كبيره
توزعت قرابه 70,000 نسخه همم كان مجله
اسبوعيه
ثم ما توقفت هذه الجريده الاخوان لا
يستطيعون ان يعني يمر عليهم يوم دون ان
يكون لهم منبر اعلامي فهذا التوقيت بالطبع
لم يكن نقل الانترنت ولا الفضائيات فسعوا
الى تاجير همم جرائد او الصحف لان هو لا
يستطيع ان يعني مصدر جريده باسمه لانه هو
تنظيم غير قانوني
همم لهم كان لهم تجربه شهيره مع تاجير
مساحه من جريده الشعب اللي كان بيزرها حزب
العمل برئاسه المرحوم ابراهيم شكري